a school day scenes familiar in homes
right across the country but Abby's is
different
she has three children the eldest of
whom is severely autistic and yet due to
a Visa condition she's not entitled to
any state support that means no respite
care no child benefit
no access to many other sources of help
even though her daughter is a British
citizen
the kind of job I do is a Dom's Larry
job sometimes I'll be at work and um the
school might call me that something is
wrong I have to just leave the work I
once I've left the work I don't get paid
for the rest of the day I need to manage
and manage you know the younger ones as
well so it's really really difficult
around one and a half million people in
the UK live with what's called no
recourse to public funds the government
says they should pay their own way but
the home office has continued to deny
support to those who like Abby find
themselves living with disability or
those who fall suddenly ill making it
impossible to work that is until now
a court order seen exclusively by Sky
News has ruled that the home office
policy is unlawful particularly in its
failure to consider disability as grinds
for potentially requiring people to
access public funds it means the policy
will have to be changed and potentially
hundreds of people like Abby those
struggling with disability will be able
to access help now I have access to so
many helps she needs I can apply for
them and they'll give it to her and um I
think there's going to be a lot of
changes now I'm so excited about that
but it's not the first time the very
same policy brought in as part of
Theresa May's hostile environment has
been struck down by the courts as the
lawyer who brought the case knows all
too well there are no recourse to public
funds policy has now been found on an
awful five times in as many years in
lots of different respects and that's
because of a fundamental problem which
is that it strips people of the the
basic right to ensure that their
subsistence needs are met that their
essential living needs a matter that
they can they and their children and
their loved ones can live in adequate
accommodation
the home office told us in a statement
that the provision of no recourse to
public funds has been upheld by
successive governments and maintains
that those coming to the UK should do so
on a basis that prevents burdens on the
taxpayer strong and important safeguards
have been put in place to ensure the
vulnerable can receive support
life without the welfare safety net is
often precarious this is a flying lizard
now at least for some families it should
be an easier path to walk
you Thompson Sky News